uh so we'll have our second talk
starting now it's a great pleasure to
have
fahim bacchus uh speaking he's at the
unit at the university of toronto uh
he's worked extensively in many areas
including but not exclusively in status
liability
it's constraint satisfaction problems
and optimization
and he's speaking on sat for
optimization
so thanks sam and thanks everybody
for this opportunity what i want to do
today is i want to
sort of given the the title of the
workshop the 50 years in set
i want to kind of give an overview of
what's been happening
in using sat for optimization and talk
about where we stand
so there'll be some details but a lot of
it will be kind of like
um a an overview of what's
where the field stands so let's see
so if we go back since the title of the
workshop is 50 years outside of a
liability 50 years ago is when steve
cook wrote his paper
beautiful paper complexity of theory
improvement procedures
and in that paper he showed that any
instance of a decision problem in np
could be encoded into a similarly sized
sat formula
which is satisfiable if and only if the
answer to the decision problem is true
and in fact that's that formula was a
cnf sab formula
and then about a year later richard carp
produced another nice paper which showed
there was a whole bunch of other
problems
well-known combinatorial problems that
were equally as hard
as satisfiability and that all of these
problems were basically equivalent
all np complete problems what's
interesting with respect to what i'm
going to talk about today
is that of these problems that
carp talked about 12 of those
20 problems are actually decision
versions
of optimization problems problems like
clique or chromatic number
these were specified as asking the
question
was there is there a clique of a certain
size key
and that was a decision problem but in
many cases
the natural question for this is for
example what is the chromatic number of
a graph
in other words what's the minimum number
of colors needed the color graph
now you can convert that to a decision
problem which is
can the graph be colored in k colors but
really often what we want to do is solve
the optimization problem
so what's interesting about this
connection is that it sort of gives you
an immediate
approach for using sat for
solving optimization because if you want
to solve an optimization problem like
the chromatic
number you can ask a series of sat
decision problems
so you can ask can you color the graph
with one color
can you color with two colors all the
way up to some k colors
and basically as soon as you find the
first value k
for which in the sad decision problem
says yes
then you know the chromatic number is
key
and in fact this idea persists
all the way through even to today and
all of the uses that we have for sat
in solvent optimization
all of the modern techniques eventually
come down to
answering a series of set decision
problems
and what has happened in the field and
in this area
is the types of decision problems that
are asked
and the encoding of these individual
problems
that's where a lot of innovation has
occurred
in order to make more effective decision
problems
and smaller sequences of decision
problems
that can then solve the optimization
problems
and um a lot of this work about what
decision problems to ask
and how to encode these decision
problems has
in fact occurred in work on max set
and we're going to talk about some of
that work
now of course neither coke nor carp
provided useful answers
to the question about how to encode a
problem
into sat in cook uh cook's paper he
provided a
encoding that was general it was the
encoding of the states
of a torn machine as it did its
computation he had to do that because he
wanted to prove that every single
decision problem in np could be encoded
as assad formula
and of course carp wasn't looking to
encode into sat he was looking in code
set
into other problems to show that these
other problems were just as hard as sat
since he knew that sat was np complete
nonetheless in the subsequent 50 years
since
those papers many different setting
codes have been developed
for a range of different problems and
the importance of good encodings
cannot be overestimated in fact modern
sat solvers don't solve sat
they saw good encodings of set
fortunately for
the use of set of modern sat solvers
many times when you just write down the
natural encoding of a problem
and then you run for example set
pre-processing techniques
you will get a pretty good encoding and
that's made sat solvers
very applicable but if you give a sense
over a bad encoding
or even a simple problem it won't get
very far
so let me talk now a little bit more
about the kind of optimization problems
that we're going to
look at and we're going to focus on
problems where you have a bunch of
propositional variables
you have a feasibility condition which
you can think of as a being
a boolean function uh from these
optimizations from these propositional
variables are true false
and you have some sort of objective
function which maps maybe to the
rationals non-negative rational values
and in particular if i get a truth
assignment
pi to the variables then
if i ask the feasibility function does
this truth assignment map to true then
that assignment
can be called feasible and that
assignment is going to be minimal have a
minimal objective function
a value if for any other truth
assignment that's feasible
then that implies the objective function
evaluated on
pi is at least as small as the objective
function evaluated on this other
um truth assignment so that's sort of a
standard
formalization of optimization but in
this case
with respect to boolean variables
now if you have an optimization problem
of this sort
what we're going to do is we're going to
use this notation the cnf of
fee at q to denote
the sat instance which is the sad
decision problem
which is the instance is satisfiable if
and only if there exists a feasible
truth assignment
whose objective value is less than equal
to q
so then the the c f conversion of this
decision problem is just
you convert the feasibility function to
c and f
and you convert this assertion that your
objective function
is less than equal to q to c and f and
if if the feasibility
criteria and the objective function
decision
are both in p then you can get a
polysized
cnf encoding but whether or not that cnf
encoding is actually
useful in practice depends on the
quality
and of the encoding for some problems
it's a
can be done if you can solve this these
formulas
uh with a sats formula whether that's
over in other problems
it's not so hard fortunately for many
interesting problems you can solve
these cnfs and therefore you can use sat
to solve optimization
now like i said before a lot of the
innovation on using sat for optimization
has occurred
in the area of max set so what we're
going to do is we're going to
concentrate on that formalism
for representing optimization problems
from here on so this is sort of the
general optimization function
that you might think about solving with
sat and we're going to talk about the
more specific
formulaization in maxset
so in maxset what you have again is you
have a set of propositional variables
and now you have two sets of clauses a
set of heart clauses
and a set of soft clauses and associated
with every soft clause
is a weight that is positive weight is
up
greater than zero and most of the max
set solvers
are restricted to integer weights but
not all of them
so now you're going to say that a truth
assignment is feasible
if it satisfies the hard clauses and
the cost of a feasible solution
is simply the sum of the weights of the
soft clauses that it
falsifies and that the feasible solution
is
optimal if it has minimum cost
among all of the feasible solutions
and so therefore if you solve a max at
instance
you're going to look for a feasible
solution and of course
there's a strong correlation between the
more general optimization function
problems
and maxsat in particular the feasibility
condition
for maxsat is simply the hearts which in
some sense
is a cnf encoding of the feasibility
conditions
and now the objective function on the
other hand is more
stylized in max set what you have to do
is you have to find a set of solved
clauses
such that when you ask what is the
amount
of weight that's falsified by a
truth assignment pi it has to be equal
to this objective function
here and sometimes you can do this
translation to a set of solved clauses
and for some objective functions you
can't but in general
if you can get an encoding of this
optimization problem
into cnf you can typically get an
encoding
into mac set now the practicality of the
max set encoding
as compared to solving the individual
set encodings might differ in particular
these individual set encodings are
encodings for specific
values of the optimization function
whereas the max adding code in is kind
of an encoding that captures
all values of the all possible values of
the objective function
so it could be that if you fix the value
of the reactive function to this value
q you get a simpler encoding but
sometimes the max add encoding can also
be
quite effective and um so that's
why max add has become very popular and
useful
for solving optimization is that often
you can get a good
max having code so a simple example
just to get us all on the same page
if you have a graph and you want to find
a maximum click
what you could do is you could say
define a propositional variable for
every vertex
and these propositional variables mean
that if the propositional variable is
true
it means that that corresponding vertex
is part
of your maximum clique and then your
feasibility condition
or just simply the set of clauses that
well if you don't have an edge between
vi and vj then either vi is not in the
clique
or vj is not in the clique and then now
the sat decision problem
would be that well you have this
feasibility clauses
you have these variables and the
objective function
for a particular value of k would be
that the sum
of the propositional variables uh vi
is less than equal to k and you can
convert these sums
to c and f so that's you can do that as
a sat decision problem but in max set
you can see that in this particular case
you get an even simpler formulation
which is that the sauce just cause
of variables true as possible
in other words i want to make the clip
as big as possible
and any time i remove i i don't include
something in the click i pay a cost
so there's a couple other things i need
before i get into sort of where we are
at with respect to optimization
in the current state of the art uh one
is that
to note that any max sas instance can be
converted to one where every single
soft clause is a unit clause over
positive variables
and this transformation for example is
described in our
um handbook chapter on max set
that i wrote with matthew jarrus level
and reuben martens
so then the softs always look like this
they're always unique clauses
over very over positive variables so
we're going to use that in what follows
the second thing that we're going to use
a lot is
cardinality constraints and a lot of
work has been done in this area
which is the question of how do you
encode
a summation over some input literals
and different techniques have been
developed for doing that
so you have a cnf which is over these
input variables
and over these output variables
these sk and what you have
is you want to encode the condition that
if you make one of these
output variables false that's going to
serve as an upper bound
on how many input variables can be true
so if you make
s i false then the clauses in this
encoding
will force this
the constraint that at most k input
variables
can be true and there's different
encodings that have been used
in mac's network one of the most popular
is this totalizing coding uh described
in this paper here
so that means that you can put an upper
bound
on how many input variables are true for
example if i say that
s 3 is false
then i have imposed a constraint that
the sum over these input variables
is less than three and we're going to
use that as well
and then the final component that we're
going to use
in describing max type procedures
is sat solve them with assumptions and
the way this works if you've not seen it
before
is that you have a formula a cnf formula
f
and you have a set of assumptions and
these assumptions
are literals that you're going to assume
and you're going to ask the sat solver
to solve
f subject to those assumptions
the sat solver will return sat if it can
find a truth assignment that satisfies
the formula
f and as well makes every assumption
true so it satisfies every literal in
the assumptions
otherwise it's going to return onset
and it will return a conflict clause
over these assumptions in other words
it'll say
some subset of these assumptions at
least
one of this subset must be false you
can't make
all of these assumptions true at least
one of these
must be false okay so
most sat solvers provide this facility
and it's actually quite a simple
facility to implement
but we're going to use this a lot
okay so that's uh our background is any
questions about
that material so
if not we'll go now into talking about
how do maxsat solvers generate a good
sequence of sad queries that allow them
to efficiently solve
optimization problems using sat queries
well let's take a simple the simplest
approach as an example first
just to get our cells in sync with what
we're going to be doing here
so if you have a formula max set formula
where all of the clauses have unit cost
so you have a bunch of unit cost
solves then you can do the obvious
which is the first idea that we had
which is you can ask the sequence of
sad queries is the formula satisfiable
falsifying no more than zero sauce
is it satisfiable falsifying no more
than one solved
satisfiable false fine no more than case
offs
so you ask this sequence of set queries
and you stop as soon as the answer is
yes
and then you know that you can find a
solution satisfying only k
subs and how would you do this in
practice
well you would have the hard clauses
and of course you have the soft clauses
which are unit
soft clauses and what you do is you feed
the negations of those soft clause
variables into a cnf encoding
of cardinality constraint which sums up
those
soft clauses so we we know how to do
that
and this c and f encoding basically sums
how many soft clauses are falsified
then all you need to do is use sat
solving with assumptions
and the first thing you do is you ask
can you solve this
formula which is this cnf formula
along with these hearts can you solve
that problem
by when s1 is false in other words when
zero false zero solves are falsified
and if you can't do that can you solve
it when one soft
is falsified and when two solves are
satisfied and you keep on going
and so this gives you a very simple way
in which you can set up
one formula and then through a sequence
of sat solving with assumptions find the
optimal
now
as i mentioned before this may not be as
efficient
as encoding each one of these problems
individually
with a fixed value of the objective
function
but in the cases where it is uh it can
be okay
and now of course you don't have to go
from zero to n as we did here you can go
from n to zero or you can do binary
search
you can do diff different sorts of
searches for finding the value
where you transition from zapd on set
now the binary search idea seems
attractive
because you're going to do less sat
solves but
that's kind of misleading because it
turns out
that these individual sat solves
vary quite considerably in their
complexity
so if you were to ask yourself okay is
this
solvable and then if it is not solvable
is this one solvable so you do some sort
of binary search
these individual sat solves might be
very difficult far more difficult
than just going right across from
smallest
to biggest so it's quite unpredictable
that way
now the problem with this approach and
why this approach
this simple approach doesn't really work
very well
is that you're not telling the sats over
much
you're basically saying to the sat
solver when you
for example set this assumption to be
false
so that's over go off and look at the
formula and see if you can satisfy this
formula
for any choice of two soft clauses
you can satisfy so in general you are
giving the sat solver
freedom to look for all possible choices
and choose k where you're going to set
falsify
case solve clauses and that's quite a
big search space
because you're not constraining it in
any way
and in fact the fundamental problem with
this approach
is that when you have a max hat formula
with a million soft closes
or a hundred thousand even a hundred
thousand this encoding
of the cnf which sums up the soft
clauses
just blows up it gets giant and
even though you can construct it
incrementally it still blows up
as the lower bound goes up
so it doesn't work very well in practice
so this layer here
becomes extremely big
so um that's has led
to sort of what sort of the current the
state of the art
uh for um one of the one of the
approaches for max
and silvers which is to use cores
to guide the sequence of sad queries
you're going to make
and this idea started off with a nice
paper by foon malik
where what they did is they used
basically the unset the clause that you
got back
from the sat solving with assumptions to
give more direction
to the sat solver in the next query
and so they use what are known as cores
they call these ids
these clauses cores
and now chords are used in different
ways in almost every single
state-of-the-art set solver
and for our purposes we can just think
about the cores
as being the subsets of negated
assumptions
that were returned by the sat solver
when you solved under
assumptions and these are clauses that
are entailed
by the current set of hard clauses and
in this context what they're going to
correspond to we're going to see this
more clearly in a bit
they're going to correspond to
constraints on which
and how many soft clauses must be
falsified
in order to make the formula satisfiable
so i'm going to give you one example of
how these cores are used
in kind of like a state of the art way
and this
is uh the oll system
and this was used for example in some
very good set solvers like rc2
max hat solvers rc2 maxino uh
university of warsaw hat and was first
described in this paper
in 2014 although the idea stems from
earlier work in i believe answer set
programming
so again let's look at this simple
example
in this example we have eight soft
clauses
and we have a bunch of heart clauses so
the first thing we're going to do in
this algorithm
is we're going to try to solve the hard
clauses
as making all of the soft clauses true
so we're going to assume that each of
these soft clauses are true
try to satisfy them all and in my group
diagrams
i'm going to put a red circle around the
literals that i'm assuming to be false
so i'm assuming that the negations of
these
soft clauses are false in other words
that the soft clauses are true
so that's your first sensor now suppose
you get onset i can't do it i can't
satisfy all eight
soft clauses and i get back then uh
some subset of these assumption literals
negated which is a implied
by the formula and let's say that we get
well i can't satisfy all of the heart of
the soft clauses
because i must falsify at least
one of b1 to b5
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to build a new
cardinality constraint whose inputs
are exactly the literals from this
core this clause that i got back
from sat solving under assumptions
and so i build myself a new cardinality
constraint
which sums up these literals that i got
back
and adds these new summation literals
and now what do i know well i know
that the previous satsov has
told me that one of these self-clause
one of these literals must be false
therefore this summation must add to at
least
one so i can set s1 to
1 and i
i want to falsify no more than that
i know that i have to falsify one soft
clause
and it must be one of these self-clauses
but otherwise i don't want to falsify
anymore
so then i can assume that well let me
make sure
that among these clauses i falsify at
most
one so i assert not s2
and the remaining soft clauses i must
make them
true so i assume all of those
now i do a sad solve again
but i wanted to notice the first thing
is that
i have built myself a cardinality
constraint
but that cardinality constraint is over
only the soft the literals
that appeared in the core which is
a much much smaller subset
than the set of all soft clauses
so typically in most instances
you might get 50 soft clauses
in your core even when you have a
hundred thousand soft closes
so you're building yourself a
cardinality constraint over a very
much smaller set of
soft clauses and therefore the size of
this cardinality constraint
in terms of the cnf representation is
much smaller
so okay and the second thing you've done
is that you've not only told the sat
solver go and try and find
a satisfying solution
which falsifies only one soft clause
you've told it
that all of the ones that you must
falsify
you can only falsify one of these so
you've restricted
the choices that sat solver can look at
in terms of which next one it should
falsify
so again you've made the stencil much
simpler so what you do okay is you do
this
additional sets all and suppose you get
onset
one more time and you get a new core
well again the new core has to be
um a negation of one of these literals
here
that's what this the satsang solving
under assumption does
for you and so for example say that you
get that well
you know i i have to make at least s
two or not or or
not b six one of those has to be true
that's what the set solve is telling you
so now you build
again a new cardinality constraint over
those two input variables
and you so you create now you've created
two
cardinality constraints that you added
to the formula
which had these original set of
feasibility constraints
and now again you know that for this
cardinality constraint
at least one of its inputs must be true
for this cardinality constraint
at least one of its inputs must be true
but you don't want more than two of them
to be true
so you said this you don't want either
one of these to be falsified
so you set this and you don't want more
than one
of these from this cardinality
constraint to be true
and now you can set yourself up the next
set solve
which involves these assumptions and if
we look at this more carefully
it's not hard to see that what you've
done here
is you've basically gotten information
from the two sets all you've done that
one of these
self one of these literals must be false
so you've allowed the sat solver to do
that
and that either it's the case
that two of these that's what this s2
means
two of these literal
two of these literals are falsified
or this one is falsified and that's what
this
cardinality constraint encodes
and that's the information you're giving
to the set solver
when you're asking it to find now a
solution
that falsifies at most two soft clauses
you've also given it this information
from you've gotten from the other
previous two set solves and that makes
it
much more efficient
and um and you keep on going and this
works out
this works pretty good um uh
it's one of the best ways of solving
smack sat
now some interesting questions that has
arisen from
this line of work is that there are many
different ways
of generating these new cardinality
constraints
from the cores that have been developed
and some ways are more efficient than
others and it's
not yet clear there's a deeper
understanding of where the efficiency
differences lie
remains an open question
is for example can you argue for example
that this particular oll method is using
all of the information that it got from
the previous set
solves it seems like it is but it would
be nice to formalize that notion
now the other issue with this approach
to doing optimization is the sat
decision problems
are growing in size after every core is
found
because you have to add a cardinality
constraint
to the sat formula every time you do one
of these iterations
and so for problems where you need
many iterations what will happen
what doesn't tend to happen is the sat
decision problems become
too large or too hard to solve
and this is particularly a problem when
you start dealing
with non-unit weighted soft clauses
because there what happens is that
especially with
instances with many diverse weights what
you end up with
is you end with many iterations because
basically what's happening
is you have to start examining all of
the possible different sums
that these diverse weights could
generate and as you might know
there it basically um
it doesn't take too many diverse weights
to generate a tremendous number
of diverse weights in their subset sums
so these schemes for example on problems
with more than 50 distinct soft clause
weights
tend to not work very well
now an alternate approach is an approach
that's come out of my research and my
students research
and also picked up by others is an
implicit hidden set approach which
tries to generate use a sequence of
satellites
that are quite different from the core
based
approaches and this work
originated in the phd thesis of davies
in 2013.
and the idea is very simple so
you are going to call a clause entailed
by the formula
f we're going to say that that clause is
a core
if it contains only negated soft clause
variables
so for example if the soft clauses are
b1
to bn then a clause like not b2
not b5 not b10 not b12 it's a core
because it only contains negated soft
clusters in other words it's saying
this clause is saying that at least one
of these soft clauses
must be falsified
so that means that if you have a set
of cores a whole bunch of such clauses
and you have any truth assignment which
is feasible
any feasible truth assignment then that
feasible truth assignment
must falsify at least one soft clause
from every core in this set k
in other words it must satisfy every
clause
in k now if we look at the set
of soft clauses that are falsified
by a feasible truth assignment pi let's
call that set a
we see then that if we regard these
clauses as being sets
of self of literals
we see that this set of
clauses that are falsified by pi is in
fact a
hidden set of my set of course
in other words it has a non-empty
intersection with every member
of my set of course
so that tells us then that if we could
compute
a minimal cost citizen of my set of
cores
that means that since every feasible
solution gives me falsifies a set of
clauses
that is a hidden set the cost of every
feasible solution
is going to be an upper bound in other
words
the minimal cost hidden set is going to
be a lower bound
on the cost of any feasible solution
so that means it's going to be a lower
bound on the cost of an optimal solution
so therefore if i can find any set of
cores
and any feasible solution where the cost
of my feasible solution in other words
the sum of the weights
of the clauses it falsifies if that
cost of that feasible solution is equal
to the weight
of the minimal cost hidden set then i
have a verification
that my feasible solution is in fact
an optimal solution and this leads to
this very simple algorithm
for finding an optimal solution now this
is an algorithm that is no longer used
in practice
the version that's used in practice like
for example in my max sets over max hs
uses instead uh upper and lower banks
so it looks much more like a traditional
optimization algorithm
but this is the simple algorithm that
gives us an idea of how this works
you start off with an empty set of cores
and a hidden set of that empty set of
chords
which of course is an empty set too
you then do a set solve
under assumptions you solve this hards
and you ask it to also solve
all of the source except those that are
in the hidden set
and if the result is set then you found
a set
of optimal solution if the result is
unset
then you have returned yourself a
conflict
and that conflict you can add to your
set of course
and now you can recompute your minimal
cost
hidden set and you go again and why does
this work
well what if if this is satisfiable
what can pi falsify it can only falsify
the clauses that
soft clauses that are it has to satisfy
all of the self-clauses
that are left after you remove the
hidden set
so therefore the cost of the self
clauses it
falsifies can is upper bounded by the
cost
of this hidden set which is of course
a minimum cost hidden set and of course
we know that the bound goes the other
way
so it must be that the cost of pi
is in fact equal to the cost of the
minimal cost hidden set
and it must be optimal and on the other
hand
if you get unset uh you have returned
yourself a core
so you have to terminate because there's
only a finite number of cores
now um you need of course a method for
compute and minimal cost hidden sets
and in practice um
integer programming solvers are often
used for this purpose
um and like i said
modern the modern approach to using this
utilizes upper and lower bounds rather
than this
more simple algorithm i just presented
now in some cases it turns out that the
hidden set
problems that you produce you can show
that they can be solved in polynomial
time
and that was for example used in this
nice paper
to show that under a particular encoding
they're called the durability encoding
this approach
implicit head and set approach can solve
pigeonhole
in polynomial time because the hidden
set
problem that's generated can be solved
in polynomial time
and you only need to do this generate a
polynomial number of
cores all of which can be done in
polynomial time
so that paper sort of gives you an
indication that this method
gives some interest in different power
over simple
uh set solving
now one of the difficulties and this is
what i sort of last thing i want to talk
about
of this implicit hidden set approach is
that well it does fare better
when you have a large number of diverse
weights
because then actually the hidden set
problem becomes easier to solve
because there are less symmetries in the
hidden set problem
because the weights are so different
but the approach can require computing
an exponential number of course and this
is some recent work that i've done and
let me explain
this idea let's define this notion of
what i would call
exchangeable set of soft clauses and for
simplicity let's just restrict ourselves
to unit weight soft clauses you can lift
this notion of exchangeability
to weight itself closes too but it's
simpler to think about
when you have unit soft closes
so say that we have a subset of soft
clauses
so we have the the formula it has some
soft clauses
and we have a subset of soft clauses and
the size of this subset
is n we're going to say that it's
extreme this soft set of
clauses is exchangeable when
for every feasible truth assignment that
happens to falsify
k soft clauses in our set e
there exists another and choose k
feasible truth assignments all of which
satisfy exactly the same softs
outside of e and falsify
a different size k subset of e
in other words it doesn't matter which
particular soft clauses in e
you falsify all that matters is that you
falsified
k sub clauses and you can falsify
any k soft clause and still get a
feasible solution
so that's this notion of exchangeability
and it's a semantic notion of symmetry
and as we
discussed in the in marine's paper
it turns out that if you look at most
max hat formulas even
formulas that are specifically designed
to
have this kind of exchangeability
they are syntactically never
symmetric so if you run standard
symmetry detection
mechanisms which work on the syntax
they never detect symmetries but these
semantic symmetries
do seem to exist quite frequently
now what happens when you have an
exchangeable set of soft clauses
well it leads to an explosion in the
number of cores
that the formula has and it's not hard
to prove
that if you have a core c1
to cm in other words a set of soft
clauses
one of which has to be falsified and you
have an exchangeable set
e then if this the
intersection if k elements of this
exchangeable
set appear in our core in other words
the
size of the intersection between the
core and the exchangeable set is
k then it turns out that there exists
n choose k other cores that are similar
to this core in other words what you can
do is simply
replace the set of soft clauses that are
in
e and you can get another chord and so
you get
this explosion in the number of cores
and in davis's thesis what she proved
is that if you have the entire set of
soft clauses being exchangeable
you have a formula where the entire set
of
soft clauses are exchangeable then she
proved that the
implicit hidden set approach will
require an
exponential number of cores to make the
lower bound
reach the optimal cost i don't know
if are my conjecture is that this holds
also
when you have only a subset of soft
clauses that are exchangeable
but i haven't yet been able to prove
that
then with this idea what we did
in 2020 is we developed a method
that tried to circumstance this problem
of the exponential number of cores that
might be required
because of exchangeable scope clause
sets
in particular what we did is we
exploited the fact
that you will get a lot of soft cores
with variable with clauses from this
exchangeable set
and we use that idea to detect when
sets of soft clauses were likely to be
exchangeable
and then we've when we detected a set of
soft clauses
that are likely to be exchangeable we
developed a method where we could ex
abstract those
soft clauses and talk about their
summations
rather than their identities
how many clauses in this set are
falsified rather than which ones
and allow the sat solver to generate
abstract cores
which could compactly represent
basically an exponential number
of ordinary course and this method
worked very well in practice
it allowed max hs for example to
be the best performance householder in
the unweighted
category in last year's competition but
the theoretical underpinnings of this
are still working progress
i think the other thing that's quite
interesting about this idea
is that these kinds of symmetries which
foil the solver seem quite common
and it's interesting that in the
previous talk
that this also seems to happen in
ordinary sat solving
where uh the these pr clauses
seem to get around some of that so
uh that's kind of my overview of where
we're standing
with using sat for
um optimization um
and i'll welcome any questions
all right thank you for the talk very
nice i'll applaud on everyone's behalf
and uh let's see please either speak up
and ask questions uh looks like it or
put something in the chat window so
please anyone can volunteer
um while you're formulating your
questions i have one question myself
earlier in the talk you talked about the
summation thus this the cnf encodings
of the cardinality constraints blowing
up very
very badly what does that mean does that
mean quadratically or
yes it's quite dramatically and so when
you have a hundred thousand inputs
you're out of luck okay
right okay i mean you could do certainly
quasi-linear in principle but
i've assumed people try that and yes
so so what happens is that you get this
trade-off
there are encodings which are
i i don't know the full details
they're certainly polynomials but i
think it's quadratic
you get this trade-off where
you can encode it just simply for
example as adders
but then you don't get much propagation
you don't get much inference from um
going backwards which is what you need
uh unit propagation so they become
quite weak until you've set lots of the
inputs
okay
all right all right but even even i
think even
with the like if you encode it as adders
the other problem of course is the
adders
have xors and you start to get a lot of
xors in your formula
and that also slows the solver down so
it's sort of like
it's a it's more practical than a
theoretical question really
which is they're kind of like no nice
way of of encoding these
large very large cardinality constraints
okay okay um
armin has a question in the chat window
um
right so um you're using still using iop
solvers
yes um i am
now i suspect that for
the case where you have unweighted
self-closes
you could use a set-based approach
maybe by recursively calling call-in
max at solver and that might actually
work
just as well as the ifp solver
what happens however is the in the
unweighted case
it doesn't work as well the ilp solver
seems to work
much better in the unweighted case
so we or sorry in the weighted case we
have many diverse weights
so i would like to move away from using
the ilp solver because
what we're using is currently
proprietary software although it's
available to academics
but i haven't found an alternate
approach
the other thing i would say about the
ilp solvers
is that they give you other resources
which are useful so we had another paper
where we did reduce
cost fixing which is a ilp technique
and that also is very helpful
in solving these formulas
there's a question from uh from is
chiara macrish uh
he writes are you convinced the
commercial mit p solvers are even
producing the right answers in the
weighted case
no we're not convinced
and in fact verification of the answers
is difficult what we do know
is that the way the solver will work
is that the the the mip
solver will produce a candidate
hidden set the sensor
will then produce a
satisfy feasible solution with that cost
and that's when we terminate now
[Music]
if the ilp solver is incorrect
its bound will be wrong but we still
will get a feasible solution
so if the sensor is correct of course it
may also be incorrect
you know that at least the solutions you
get in
are feasible and they have that cost
where you what you where you don't get
the verification
is that you don't get the verification
that that's the optimal cost
and to get that verification what you
would need to do is you need to prove
that the next lowest cost is unset
so you could potentially do that if the
problem is not
too difficult you could find the optimal
solution
and then in a separate
sat solvent episode verify that you
cannot solve the problem
with anything less than that
and then check that proof
so then you can you can easily verify
that your feasible solution is a
feasible solution
that achieves that cost and then you can
check that the uh
any other thing is unsatisfiable with
the proof
so you're not really tied to the
um uh exactness or the pro the
the correctness of the commercials lip
solvers
okay any other questions
comments back
so one thing i would say as well which
is an interesting maybe there's
some other responses i can get is that
these
cardinality constraints i think are very
interesting what's happening with
when you solve these max formulas
is you're kind of generating extension
variables
it's not hard to see that for example s2
is really an extension variable it's
saying
that uh at least one of these
inputs is true and the relationship
between
um adding these kinds of cardinality
constraints
and adding extension variables is an
interesting one
that i wonder whether or not a judicious
use
of detecting when this might be useful
in order many sat solvers could also be
beneficial
there's another question
i'll i'll read it out here in admon's
talk a couple days ago
he used as costs the product of literal
costs
does this fit your unit soft model unit
soft claws model
um no uh
but you can of course
um if for example yeah you use
as a max out solver like maxikis
which allows you to use
floating point weights
you can of course use the logarithmic
logarithms
so the sum of the logarithms would then
be the products so that would be a
simple translation
so the the product of the literal costs
are
used to get yourself probabilities
so that's where that comes from so if
you do the log transformation
you can get um a
max that formula where you're adding up
the costs and in fact maxsat has been
used in this way
to solve um most probable
explanation problems npe problems uh
where you are using the logarithm
to get uh convert the product into the
sum
very good last chance for questions or
comments
otherwise thank you again uh fine
and also marine uh for two really
excellent talks
very very nice to have you here today so
and uh oh there's a comment in the chat
window that for those of you who are
simon's participants there's a
possibility to go to gather town
afterwards
and chat there on the link in the chat
window
so um again thank you everyone
and see you next week or in gather town
actually
right